Alex,
welcome to the show
Alex.
Optimal.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living this year.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
I deconstruct world class performers of all sorts of types ranging from
billionaire investors to chess prodigies to actors,
to writers,
to athletes and everything in between.
In this episode we have a real treat and it's a two part episode with Alex
Bloomberg who is very well known as a producer for this American life cohost of
planet money and also the cofounder of gimlet media,
which has currently to blockbuster podcasts.
Start up and reply all and in the first part,
which you're currently listening to,
we're going to talk to Alex about all sorts of aspects of the business of
storytelling,
the art of storytelling,
including gear that he uses,
etc. The second part is going to be an excerpt from a class that he taught on
creative live.com normally costs about a hundred dollars.
And I advised that company,
so I was able to pull out about a half hour of his teaching a class about the
art of the interview,
crafting the perfect question,
et cetera.
That is part two.
I implore you to listen to both.
I really enjoyed this.
And without further ado,
please enjoy Alex Bloomberg.
Alex,
welcome to the show.
Great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
And I have to start off because we have been scheduling and I know you're racing
to get a show out the door.
Does it ever get any easier?
I hope so.
I really hope so.
Uh,
it is,
it has been.
Yeah,
I mean it's just been,
I mean it's sort of an insane project when I'm doing,
which is it,
which is trying to,
you know,
uh,
create a regularly occurring documentary podcast about a company that's starting
up while at the same time trying to start that company.
So it's been sort of like,
I don't,
it's a cause both of them are sort of full time jobs.
Um,
so,
yeah.
And how do you,
how do you balance,
because I've listened to every episode of startup and he followed a very closely
for a whole host of reasons.
How do you balance the realtime documentary nature of,
uh,
of the show with planning,
say an editorial calendar and actually having things locked and loaded and ready
to go in advance?
Oh,
uh,
well I don't balance it.
That's the problem.
Like that we don't have things locked and loaded and ready to go in advance.
Like we don't,
we,
we were,
uh,
editing
the,
we were,
we'd just finished editing this week's episode this morning and then we just
tracked it.
That's why I was a little late with you.
[inaudible] I was tracking it in the studio today and then it'll go up tonight.
So that's how close to the wire we are.
I mean we're just,
we're,
you know,
things are,
and you'll hear this episode is all about,
it's all about burnout and it's all
how,
I was wondering,
I was wondering when that episode would come.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
cause there was a period where,
where I think there's a period in a,
in a company's life where people are like,
well this is just the startup.
This is the start of experience.
And then there's a point at which maybe like probably about right about Ron
where we are at four or five months into it,
we're like,
it's a startup but it shouldn't be this hard.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
so we,
it sort of realizing like we have to,
um,
we had to,
we have to,
we have to change.
Some things,
have to add some more support.
Um,
and part of it,
it's just like,
you just don't know,
you know,
like I didn't know,
I mean,
you know,
you,
you don't know what's possible.
And so,
so we started out,
I think we,
we just didn't have enough capacity to do what we were trying to do.
And what is,
what is your current team look like if,
well,
first question is what is tracking?
I'm still a novice at this and um,
I have a ton of questions,
but what is tracking exactly?
Yeah,
so tracking.
So when,
when you're doing sort of a documentary style podcast,
which is sort of the kinds that we do where,
where you're,
uh,
we have a script.
Um,
and so what I'll do is I'll go out and I'll gather tape in the field and I'll
record different conversations with people and then I will edit those down.
And so I have a bunch of sort of like basically selects tape tape that I've
gathered and I've edited down and cut.
So it's like,
you know,
I'll have like a,
maybe like,
you know,
25 minutes of edited tape.
And then what I have to do is stitch that together with a script.
And so I'll write the script and then we'll do edits on that script.
And so I'll read it aloud in the office.
We'll all sit around a table,
sort of like a table read,
I guess I'll sit around,
I'll read my script and I'll play the tape that I've cut from the computer where
it's supposed to go in the story and then people will give us notes on the
script and sort of say this part was dragging and this part should come earlier.
And this part you can just totally get rid of,
it's boring,
whatever.
And then you rewrite and rewrite and rewrite.
And then finally you get to the final script and then you go into the studio and
track it.
And that's when you actually just lay down your,
your,
your voice tracks.
Um,
and then those all get mixed together into the final product.
Got It.
And the,
the,
the actual reviewing of the tape.
So you capture a lot of interview,
uh,
obviously,
and I,
in one of the episodes of startup,
you had one of your employees reviewing those tapes.
Do you personally review those tapes or do you have someone do a first pass and
attempt to pull out the interesting stuff?
It
goes both ways.
I mean,
usually I've been the one getting the tape.
Uh,
so I have heard it at,
because I was there,
you know,
I was there.
Right.
You know,
with the,
you know,
with the microphone and the,
and the recorder.
Uh,
but usually it's my producer who actually does a first pass through and pulls
all the,
all the selects.
Got It.
And what are,
what are the criteria for pulling the selects?
What,
what is what makes something worth being in the show?
I think what you're asking Tim is what makes good tape,
uh,
we just,
which is,
that's right.
That's exactly what I'm asking.
That's the question that has consumed my life for the vest one years.
Uh,
so I have an answer for you.
Um,
so I think,
I think when,
you know,
one of the things that,
there's a couple of things that you looking for when you're going through the
tape.
So,
because I have a script,
because I'm narrating it,
I can sort of say pretty much all the,
all the basic information,
usually better than anybody that I'm talking to.
So what I'm going for,
our specific moments when I'm talking to people,
I'm going for a specific moments that have some kind of deep emotional resonance
or where something very live and unexpected has happened or where,
um,
there is just a very authentic emotion has been expressed.
And those are the moments that I go for.
It's almost sort of like if I'm talking to somebody about whatever,
I don't know,
just to borrow an example from my planet,
money days,
bond prices,
what I don't want is somebody talking about bond prices.
I want somebody expressing some sort of emotion about it,
if that's possible.
Uh,
you know,
because I can do all the nuts and bolts,
uh,
you know,
sort of information transfer.
And so what you're looking for in your interview subjects,
it's something,
something that,
that you can't provide yourself,
some unique perspective.
The other thing that you're going for.
The other thing.
So that's one whole category of good tape is sort of like emotionally resonant,
uh,
you know,
emotionally authentic or something where something interesting or unexpected has
happened sort of in the moment.
The other category is somebody just telling you a really good yarn,
like a really good narrative.
And so that's the other thing that we look for is sort of like,
um,
sort of at this American life.
We had a term for this,
we just call it an anecdote,
but what we really meant was a little story.
Um,
and so like,
like just for an example,
if I start to talk to you and I said,
you know,
Tim,
this morning I was leaving my house,
I was walked out the door and I was like,
I looked up in the sky and I saw something that I couldn't believe.
Like you want to hear what I said next?
Right,
right.
It's very unfulfilling story has,
so that's the story.
Like we are hardwired to be like a seat,
one sequence of action,
another sequence of action and it's going to build towards something.
We want to hear what it's building toward.
And if I say to you,
I saw something I couldn't believe a cloud,
you'd be like,
that's a boring ass story.
But if I said,
you know,
a Ufo,
then you're like,
oh,
that's an interesting story.
So,
so,
but,
but the,
the mechanics of it,
the fact that it's a story and it has a beginning and sort of,
and it like a narrative progression and sort of,
you know,
sort of rising action.
Human beings I think are sort of hardwired to want to pay attention to that.
That's,
that's what we've been telling each other for,
you know,
40,000 years.
And so,
um,
so those are the other things you're going for is like people telling you
stories
and the,
the process,
I'm so fascinated because I'm struggling with this myself,
the process of putting together an episode,
especially when you currently have the,
the real time aspect of it,
which seems to complicate matters tremendously.
Uh,
I,
if,
how many people do you currently have working,
working on each episode of let's just say startup and what are their roles?
Yeah,
I mean,
so that's the thing about this stuff is that it's like,
it's so much more time consuming then,
um,
then then the other sort of main kind of podcasts which is out there,
which is a straight interview podcasts like which we're doing,
which is w which are also like all these elements can be possible and those
kinds of podcasts as well.
And so what we're doing is sort of,
so like I go back and forth,
like,
is this insane to be spending on this time producing 20 minutes of one kind of
podcast when another kind of podcasts you could produce in 20 minutes.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
and uh,
and so what we have is we have,
um,
so right now on startup,
it's just me and my producer Kaitlin,
and then another employee,
Lisa,
who's,
um,
who's going to be producing the second season of startup.
That's not quite enough.
Um,
startup comes out every two weeks.
So we can bear.
And,
and because I've been doing this for so long and I've internalized so much of
this stuff,
like I'm a probably more productive at it than than somebody else.
But so we can bear,
we're not quite getting by with that,
but we would definitely need,
you know,
we need some more.
We need another body or two for sure.
And aside from the producer,
you also have an engineer who does yes.
Post cleanup and that type of thing?
Yes.
All right.
So we had,
yeah.
So,
so on staff is me and Caitlin,
our producer and,
and Lisa.
And then we also have other people on staff who can help with the edit,
which is a really,
really important part of it.
So,
um,
so there's other people.
So then we'll usually have one or two other people sitting in to do the edit.
So where I sit around and do the table read,
they'll give me notes and sort of say,
this part was slow,
this part wasn't.
So that's a really important thing.
And then we,
and then we,
uh,
we also outsource our transcripts,
so we have people logging all that tape.
So that it's easier to go through.
Um,
so we have people providing transcripts of the tape,
uh,
and then we have an engineer who mixes the episode,
which is,
you know,
basically everything from doing all sorts of things that I don't understand,
like putting compression on it and making it sound really good,
but also just sort of like putting it all together,
making it sound good,
making the levels right,
all that stuff.
Got It.
And the one thing that struck me about reply all the other show that I've been
listening to from,
from gimlet media is,
was listening to the launch of that and how the host's decided to join forces
with you.
And one of the things they mentioned was wanting you as an editor or having you
run to them,
run to and from the two shows,
working with them as an editor,
does that primarily mean that your,
uh,
working on the script and reviewing the transcripts or what,
what,
what is,
uh,
what are you doing as an editor?
Yeah,
I mean I think what I think of myself as,
and I think one of the reasons that I started this company,
I think my primary skill,
like the probably if I had to say like,
here's the thing that I am best at,
it is at being an editor and being an editor means,
um,
that you like.
And the way I think about it,
it's sort of like from the beginning,
it's basically being a collaborator with the hosts with a talent to getting,
you know,
the best show that you can get.
Um,
and so I tried to,
so you know,
like what that means is that when we have a weekly story meeting for reply all,
where we'll sit around for,
you know,
we'll talk for two hours,
we talked for an hour about,
you know,
what are the stories that they want to want to pursue and we'll think about
interesting angles to go at that story with.
We'll decide if they're,
if it's worth it or not.
And then we'll sort of plan like,
okay,
who do we want to talk to?
Who would be some interesting people to talk to in the story?
What questions do we want to ask them?
Like the questions are really important.
Like if you go out and you ask and you don't ask the right questions,
you can come back with nothing.
You can come back with no good tape.
And so you have to sort of design your questions so that you're sort of giving
yourself a higher chance than average of getting good tape.
Uh,
and then so we do all that.
And then when they do,
when they come back and they write the script,
then I'll,
I'll go through the script with them.
And usually we do at least one pass,
but sometimes too,
and maybe even three passes depending on how tricky a story is,
um,
where we'll really dive in deep and sort of get into the language and sort of
say this,
you know,
you're saying this,
but it's not quite right.
And so it's just,
it's,
I mean,
I think when people see it for the first time from the outside,
it's like they can't believe how much,
how much actual work goes into,
into the making of this stuff.
Um,
and I'm not sure,
you know,
like one of the big questions is sort of like how much of that work is actually
necessary,
where it can,
how much of that work is like,
are we,
are we spinning our wheels?
Um,
but my,
my contention has been that like,
to really like,
you know,
if you look at the very top of the charts and Itunes,
like a lot of those shows have that,
that amount of labor embedded in the programs that they're putting out.
Like,
I come from this American life,
which is where I learned all this stuff.
And like,
you know,
there's even more sort of editing and production work that goes into making
those shows.
Uh,
and I know certainly cereal,
um,
they were working on that for a year at least.
Um,
so,
so the,
so it,
you know,
so yeah.
So I,
so I think it's related,
but I'm not,
I'm not sure.
Oh,
it's massive.
I mean,
I was,
I was blown away and not terribly surprised when I heard that serial had a team
working on it for a year prior to the launch.
Didn't surprise me at all.
I mean,
as someone who's a very plotting writer himself didn't really surprise me.
Uh,
how did you,
how did you decide,
well,
actually before,
before I jump away from the editing,
what do you do as an editor differently from other people?
MMM,
I think is,
you're,
you're clearly,
you're clearly very good at it.
I mean,
the output of the shows reflects that.
So the question is,
you know,
maybe why aren't other people better editors or what do you do differently?
Um,
I think,
I think there's a bunch of things.
Like I said,
at first I think I learned,
I think this American life was a real editing shop.
Uh,
and I think it was,
it's a pretty special place.
Um,
like in that IRA is really,
he's a really great editor,
but he's also very encouraging to people to sort of,
um,
do their own thing.
Like it's his show,
but he really encourages you to do your own thing within that show.
Um,
so every,
when I worked there,
every story that I thought I,
that I wanted to do that I could,
that I could sort of make a good case for,
I was able to do and I was able to write it myself.
So I think part of being a good editor is being sort of,
is wanting to encourage others to sort of like having that feeling that like if,
if we're working on this together,
I can take my ego,
feels like I got some of the credit because I was in there from the beginning.
But you're also happy to share the credit with the person who's doing the story.
Um,
so I think part of it is it goes back to that sort of,
how do I think of myself as an editor,
uh,
and it,
and at this American life,
it was like sort of an elevated job.
Um,
and then I think partly it's sort of like when I got to NPR I realize that like
the conception of the job was,
you know,
your report,
it goes out,
they come back and then they play you a story and you're basically,
it's not the time,
it's the time.
You know,
you make a couple suggestions.
I didn't understand this part.
I didn't understand that part.
But you're not like thinking big about like,
well what's the idea that we're trying to go towards with this story?
What's the new thing we're trying to say?
And so I think partly also what makes a good editor is getting in there from the
beginning and talking with the reporters about what are we trying to say?
What you know,
what,
what's the interesting thing?
What's the new thing that we're going for here?
If we're doing a story that's been done a lot like,
I don't know,
politics or homelessness or whatever it is,
like something that you've heard about in the news a lot race.
Like how are we going to talk about it in a different way in a new subway in a
surprising way.
And a lot of like,
you know,
half the f you know,
a lot of the,
um,
work that makes a story good.
It goes into the very beginning.
And I think that's a lot of editors
don't think about their jobs that way.
And I think that's,
that,
that's why it's a,
and so I think that's,
that helps me,
you know,
if I'm in there from the beginning and sort of talking about it,
it's easier.
The other thing,
one other thing that I think about about editing and just quickly is that like
one of the biggest jobs of the editor is just being paying attention to your own
boredom.
Uh,
you know,
I think people would get into people who get into journalism,
get in because like I'm interested in the world and I have a natural curiosity
and I want to satisfy that curiosity.
But you know,
you gotta you're still like,
you've got to keep,
keep your audience interested and,
and,
and the editor can help do that.
Like the editor,
if you,
you have to be curious about the world that you also have to know,
like if to have as a sense and you're listening to your boredom.
It's something that I had to learn to do,
but once I did,
it's,
it's really helpful.
What are the symptoms of boredom?
So I know that might sound funny,
but uh,
what are the things,
what are these symptoms of boredom that maybe you didn't listen to?
Uh,
in the early days as much?
Well,
thank you.
Tried to sort of like,
if there's some,
if somebody reads something that is like,
it's something that you like,
that you work together,
they're sitting across the table from you and they read something that doesn't
it like maybe like sort of a boring sentence or they've come through a boring
thing or somebody is talking on tape and you don't quite know what they're
saying or what the point is because you like the person and because you know
you're a human being with decent team in emotions,
you'll,
you'll be trying to think to like,
oh,
well,
probably what the person was saying was this.
And so therefore,
you know,
though,
that all make sense because you,
you make up for the reporter who,
who's,
who's doing the read and it's,
and that's good.
That's decent human behavior to try to sort of meet somebody halfway and be
understanding and empathetic to what they're saying.
Um,
but there's something that happens on the radio or on an audio when you're
listening,
you don't listen or it doesn't do that.
And so you have to train yourself out of that instinct to make up,
to sort of fill in the gaps with what people are saying.
So one,
one sign is just the sort of glimmer of like,
wait,
I'm confused here.
And it's a very,
very,
it's often at the back of your head you don't quite get it,
but you didn't have to pay attention to it cause you sort of get what's going
on.
But there's like some,
like there's some question in your mind is like,
is that the thing that's going on that I think is,
I think it is,
but it's a very,
very slight,
and you have to train that to sort of come to the beginning of your brain,
to the head,
to the forefront of your brain.
That feeling,
because the minute that feeling happens,
you know,
this is a spot that needs to be edited.
And the other part is just sort of like,
you know,
you,
you find yourself drifting and in,
in an edit and if you're drifting in and edit,
it's not,
it's not your fault,
it's theirs.
You know what I mean?
That's hard shot.
That's what you have to do.
If I'm reading through and somebody who's listening to my story is drifting,
that is my fault.
I have to keep you from drifting.
So and so at the same thing as if the shoe's on the other foot,
then the thing is true.
If you're the editor,
your job is not to be engaged.
They're job is to engage you and,
and so and so you,
so the minute you feel yourself drifting,
that's another section that needs to be edited.
No,
definitely.
And,
and uh,
you brought up things being unclear or hard to understand.
When I found as a writer,
when I send things to my friends who are writers,
to have them proof of chapter,
if I ask them to indicate if I first asked them to indicate what they like and
dislike,
they might try to appease me or feel badly about hurting my feelings.
So I always start with just point out what isn't clear.
Usually yields a much better result because it's,
they don't feel like they're being as judgemental towards me personally.
Um,
I always find that a really helpful place to start.
And that's even more important in audio because audio is like,
you can't go back and reread audio.
You know what I mean?
Well,
now in the age of on demand audio,
you can go back,
this is true.
Or back in the radio days when there was literally no mechanism to go back and
relisten.
But,
but,
and so what happens is the minute you're listening,
if you're confused,
you're like,
wait,
what was that thing?
And you've been trying and you try to figure it in your brain,
what was the thing that was confusing you?
And then your brain has taken it's eye off the ball basically and had not
listened to the next sentence,
right?
It's coming at it.
And then it's like a train wreck.
Like you never catch up.
You know what I mean?
So one moment of confusion can utterly destroy an otherwise beautiful story,
you know?
And so you have to be on,
you have to be on,
you know,
a special garden about that.
And in audio,
I think particularly
what,
uh,
what does a producer do?
So this,
this has come up quite a bit.
You mentioned you have a producer,
a for instance.
What,
what does the,
what does,
uh,
what does for startup in particular,
what does the producer do?
What is their job?
I know it's one of those jobs.
It's the one whose words like manager,
which is like,
wait,
what with a manager?
Uh,
yeah.
um,
so a producer I think has also has many meanings,
but in my case,
what a producer does.
Uh,
so my producer,
um,
helps me think through the interviews I'm going to do.
Um,
often we'll listen back through the tape,
transcribed the tape sometimes or make sure that it's transcribed.
She will pull,
pull the interesting pieces of tape,
you know,
usually we'll consult about it,
but then she'll go and actually produce us a session in the editing software
that we use that has the polls that we want.
She'll also think through like how to structure each episode,
um,
and all sorts of other things.
Like when,
like when I was at this American life,
I was,
my job was producer.
Um,
that was what it was called.
[inaudible] and you basically help build the story with the reporter.
You know,
you're really sort of like a partner in the creation of the story and the
reporter has voices doing it.
And the reporters often sort of like writing and,
and,
and in some cases finalizing the writing in some cases really doing most of the
writing.
But really you're a team.
And,
and structuring the story is so important again in audio especially I think just
because you can get so confused easily.
So,
so,
so generally what the producers are in the audio world are,
are there experts that sort of structuring the story,
like how do you,
what's,
how does the story begin and what are the emotional moments that were leading to
and how do we contextualize those moments with script?
Um,
so often when I was a curious at this American life,
we'd be working with writers who are really good writers who had not done that
much audio.
And often what I would do is I would cut the tape and then I would have,
and then we would meet and I would just sort of talk them through like,
so we would have gone out and done a bunch of interviews.
I would cut down to the moments that we were going to use and then we'd get back
in the room and I would tell them like,
okay,
here's how I think you can start and here's what I think you want to say to
start it up.
And then we're going to go to this piece of tape and this is the first piece of
tape we're going to use.
And it introduces this character in the story.
And then from there you're going to want to write something like this.
And sometimes I would have dummy language in there and I would basically provide
a roadmap for the,
for the reporter or the writer,
they would sort of lead through the tape and get to a finished piece.
So that's,
that's,
that's got it.
That's what they do.
Yeah.
And into ATS at gimlet media,
which is of course a much smaller operation than this American life who's
handling releases and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah,
the producer would be doing that as well.
Um,
so the,
the,
yeah,
so the,
so producer is sort of like do sort of the high level conceptual structuring
stuff and then they also sort of like transcribed Cape and they also sort of
like handle all the details and make sure that the plane tickets are purchased
and you know,
you know,
various people have been set up and booked into various studios and all that
sort of stuff
with,
uh,
I know we're getting into some nitty gritty stuff,
but I'm so fascinated by it.
And then we're going to go kind of broader picture.
The what type of editing software do you use?
Uh,
uh,
pro tools,
protools and uh,
with,
with reply all for instance,
which is,
is perhaps a little more,
can be planned a little more in advance.
How from the initial idea pitch meeting to the finished episode,
How long does that currently take and how far out have you planned already?
Not necessarily gathering all the Info and doing the interviews,
but decided on the subject matter for episodes.
Well,
I mean we not as far as planned out as we want to be.
Um,
you know,
we have,
we're,
we have things on the calendar going out maybe a month or month and a half.
Um,
but you know,
it's always a race every week to get everything done,
uh,
so as especially as you'll hear in the next episode of startup.
Uh,
but,
uh,
um,
but,
uh,
and,
and so some of those are just ideas.
Some of those are like,
you know,
there's all the,
all the tape is in and it's been edited and we,
and we just have to sort of wrangle it into shape.
Um,
so,
uh,
yeah,
so,
but I would say that we don't have anything we've never had.
Our goal is to sort of get to a point where we can have everything where we can
have,
we can be a week ahead.
Like,
we can have next week's episode in the can this week,
like done,
recorded the ads,
put in everything done,
mixed the music in.
And I would say we're several months away from that goal.
Like we just,
we just need to get better at it and build that muscle.
What tools,
what tools do you guys currently use?
I,
I of course take,
I'm an avid sort of hyper graphic note taker.
I heard Chartbeat mentioned in one of the episodes.
Uh,
what type of tools do you guys use for organizing all this stuff besides
protools?
What are the,
the,
you know,
the software or the,
the,
the whiteboard.
I mean,
what,
what do you guys use?
We used actual whiteboards.
Um,
we use,
we have like little white boards,
the float around the office that have the,
sort of like the checklist of everything that needs to be done every episode.
Uh,
you know,
sort of like,
just sort of like this,
the basic stuff that you forget,
like,
you know,
did we,
did we get the ad copy correct and we'd get the,
um,
did we email all the people that we write the copy for the web,
that we,
all that stuff,
you know,
um,
did we get the list of songs that we're using in the episodes that we can put
them on the website?
Um,
and then,
um,
and then we use,
and then we co we have a lot of,
we do a lot of collaborations.
So the w most of the stuff that we write,
our scripts are all written in a Google doc.
Um,
and we have multiple people editing through the Google Doc.
that really changed my world when that came around.
Um,
uh,
and that's fantastic.
Uh,
you know,
um,
we use slack at the office like the younger guys do.
I don't really know how to use it really.
Um,
uh,
we,
um,
but there's,
I think those are the main ones.
Like the Google,
Google docs are sort of the main thing that we use to sort of collaborate right
on.
Um,
and then,
and then actual light boards.
Um,
we've scheduled stuff through Google calendar.
Awesome.
Do you use any kind of project management software,
like a base camp or a sauna or Trello or anything like that?
I have,
I have worked on projects where I've used base camp before.
Um,
like when we did our website design,
we use base camp with the design team that was designing the website and that
was really useful.
Like I find base camp too useful for like distributed teams.
Um,
when I was at planet money we did this big sort of crazy project where we
followed a tee shirt around the world as a cup made.
And we did this sort of elaborate web interactive website,
uh,
about the project where we had all these videos and stuff like that.
And that was like a couple of different teams when in New York,
one in DC and we use base camp for that project as well.
And that was really helpful.
Um,
on a day to day basis.
I don't,
I don't use it as much.
Uh,
just cause you know,
it's pretty simple what we're doing.
The bulk of our work is sort of like,
you know,
managing,
wrangling tape and writing scripts.
That's sort of like the day to day.
That's what I'm doing every day is,
is that essentially,
what do you,
what do you guys currently use for capturing tape in the field?
We use,
um,
in terms of equipment,
we use flash card recorders and uh,
and you know,
Nice,
nice microphones.
Uh,
we use,
um,
we use these tasks Cam,
uh,
task cam recorders.
Um,
some of us use Sony's,
but they're just,
they're pretty nice,
you know,
broadcast quality,
sort of,
uh,
they're not the nicest,
but the pretty nice ones.
And then we have a nice night.
No,
what type of,
uh,
if,
if you know,
offhand and I,
I'm involved with creative live,
so I managed to grab a pdf of your,
some of your gear.
I don't know if it's changed since then,
but I'm a,
I'm an advisor for creative live.
And by the way,
it's,
I,
I'm going to,
I'll link to it in the show notes for everyone,
but the,
I've been very impressed with the class.
So what,
we'll come back to that,
but it's just,
it was just the,
the masterclass in asking questions.
So of of course I have performance anxiety
right now.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Well that's why,
that's why I decided to swing completely the opposite direction and ask very
boring hyper-specific
no questions.
I mean the concrete details,
that's another one that people forget.
Like people go too broad.
And I think what's often interesting is the nuts and bolts of people's process.
So these like,
I must,
you know,
like I think often I'll ask these exact kind of questions like sort of like on a
day to day basis.
Like what are you,
when are you actually doing?
Um,
like I like I did,
yeah,
I did the Squarespace.
I do these ads,
right.
And um,
where I just interviewed somebody in the company about what their job is like
and the company that's,
you know,
that's sponsoring us.
I guess we're going to do one of these ads later.
But,
but my,
my,
my uh,
goal there is just to try to find one sort of like,
I call it like a,
um,
like a vivid moment,
a moment where it sort of like,
you know,
like if it's a,
one time I found myself talking to a treasurer of,
of one company and I was like talking and like that wasn't getting very much
vivid stuff.
I was like sort of like,
what's it like to be a treasurer and wasn't getting very much.
And finally I was like,
dude,
what's the,
you know,
do,
do you actually sign your name on the checks?
And he was like,
we have an auto center but sometimes actually sign the checks.
And then we got into this whole discussion of sort of where he sits,
when he signs the checks and how he signs them and how much time,
how long it takes and does he block it off in his calendar.
And that was like by far the best moment of the interview because it felt all of
a sudden you were like,
you actually,
it felt real,
you know,
and you've got a real sense of sort of like the details of this guy's life.
So I'm all for these kinds of,
these kinds of concrete questions.
Okay.
Well I'm going to follow on with,
with some digging then the,
I noticed in the list of equipment,
and again,
I'll link to all of this in the show notes for people,
the,
that you have a boom mic.
And I have for instance,
a zoom recorder,
a h four n and I have a,
another model.
It's a two two follow up questions.
Is there any reason you chose the tascam over zoom or anything else?
And then the second is what do you use the boom for?
Because I'm just,
when I'm sitting down with someone,
I find the,
these,
these handheld,
you know,
h the zoom recorders for instance,
uh,
work quite well by themselves.
They work even better with a lav mic or something like that or just a handheld
stage stage.
Mike connected with XLRs.
What do you use the boom mic for?
I mean I can give you a lot of bs about it,
but the truth is I don't,
it's like habit basically.
Like these are the microphones that we started using it,
this American life.
When I first got there,
I didn't know anything about audio.
I am not a super technical Lee.
Like I know a lot about like the story structure.
I don't know.
I know exactly what I need to know about a recording equipment.
Um,
I'm not super tech savvy that way.
And so,
um,
so partly it's just sort of like that's the,
those are the ones we use and I got used to them and I can hear this ad like
right now I understand like when I'm out in the field I know exactly what I
needed to do with that particular Mike to get the exact sound that I want to get
and I don't have to like mess around with something new.
Um,
the one thing that I will say that I think the reason,
so the task cam that was just,
that was the recommendation that I read on a website and I bought it and it's
worked for me,
although there are certain things that I don't love about it,
so,
um,
so I feel like you're,
you're fine.
Whatever works for you,
Fine with their,
um,
the,
uh,
the mic is more important than the recorder.
Um,
and,
and my,
so that was,
so part of it is just sort of habit part of it.
The real part I guess is,
is that
as long as it's a directional mic,
um,
what I'm trying to do often is get intimate sounding,
you know,
conversations.
And so if you have an omnidirectional mic,
uh,
which is the mix,
the Mike's Recording pattern is picking up from all around the whole field of,
you know,
where you're recording,
just,
you,
you just have to be,
you have to worry a little bit more about placement and you just,
you sometimes don't get,
it doesn't feel like they're as present.
Um,
whereas if you're using one of these,
um,
sort of unidirectional boom mikes,
like the one I use,
it's really weird.
Like when you point it at somebody,
you can hear them and when you pointed away,
you really don't hear them very well.
It really drowns out all the surrounding sound.
And so what that means is you get this pretty nice,
very,
very intimate sound.
And then if you,
and then if you're in a,
in a place where life,
lots of other stuff that's happening around and you want to document the fact
that you're out in the field and there's a rodeo going on behind you or
whatever,
you can just,
when you're done with the interview,
you just point the Mike at the Rodeo and get that ambiance and then you can just
use it as an ambiance bed.
Um,
so,
so I like,
so I like the intimacy that you get with the,
with a,
with a nice tight boom mic.
What?
No,
that makes perfect sense.
Uh,
what numbers do you check on a daily or weekly basis?
And not to beat a dead horse,
but this,
do you guys use chirpy?
Did you end up using that?
And what other,
what other numbers besides just straight forward kind of revenue numbers for
sponsors will kind of stuff do you guys check?
I mean,
if anything,
I again,
I'm,
I was obsessive Lee checking our soundcloud numbers because we hosted on
soundcloud and so I could see,
so and soundcloud feeds or iTunes.
So every time somebody,
any,
anytime somebody who subscribed to start up,
it downloads to their phone,
that registers as a play on soundcloud.
So soundcloud was documenting,
was sort of capturing both the,
the people who are listening,
streaming it through the web or through our website or whatever,
and the people who are downloading it onto their phones through iTunes or some
other pod catcher.
So it was a one stop shop for our,
for our,
for our listening numbers basically.
Um,
and so I would check that.
and that was pretty much everything that I checked.
Uh,
I didn't,
you know,
I know PJ and Alex,
the host,
the reply all are much more tech savvy,
uh,
and much more,
you know,
sort of aware of what's going on.
And so every once in a while I'll ask them sort of like,
what are they looking at?
And they look at Chartbeat a lot.
Um,
but,
but we haven't,
I don't look at that that much.
Got It.
So I want to rewind the clock a little bit and just,
uh,
I'm looking at,
I'm looking at your bio and it says you've worked as a social worker,
a caterer,
eighth grade science teacher,
and a graduate level journalism professor.
Uh,
tell me the story of how you got to radio.
yeah,
the story,
I guess the story starts.
I was in,
um,
I was a teacher.
I taught eighth grade science.
Um,
and I was,
I did that for four years and I,
this was in Chicago.
How old were you?
How old were you at the time?
Basically right at,
around what time was,
this was in my mid to late twenties.
So starting at like,
maybe like 24 to the time I was 28 or something like that,
28,
29,
I was teacher and um,
and I had,
um,
basically it starts like,
I'd always been interested in this kind of,
I guess what you'd call long form narrative nonfiction.
You know,
like I had read,
uh,
you know,
a couple of magazines since the time I was in high school.
Like I liked the New Yorker magazine and I liked Harper's magazine and,
and I liked these kind of,
and I would read these books of like,
you know,
sort of like,
um,
you know,
Joseph Mitchell,
who's the sort of famous olds,
you know,
nonfiction writer.
And I would read,
you know,
he be white and stuff like that.
Uh,
John Hershey,
you know,
the guy who wrote Hiroshima.
So,
um,
I was at Hersey Hershey,
right.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and so I was,
I was into that kind of stuff and then I would,
um,
but I never,
for some reason,
and I was pretty,
I was pretty good student and I like,
you know,
I did,
I did okay.
But some of it never occurred to me that I could actually do that.
As for living,
I don't,
and I don't know why.
Like I really don't know why I thought,
um,
I just somehow thought that like,
the people who did that where some sort of different world of people that like,
I would never be able to access that world.
And like now it's ridiculous.
Like the thought that like,
you know,
an upper middle class Jewish kid could ever make it in the media world.
Like what,
you know,
of course,
how could that happen?
I don't know why it was so,
uh,
I don't know why I was,
so,
I think it was just like a profound lack of,
I didn't know anybody who'd ever done that.
I grew up in Cincinnati,
Ohio,
which was like,
you know,
not,
not super provincial,
but just,
you know,
certainly not a media capital.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
people who have succeeded became doctors and lawyers and that was sort of it.
Um,
so,
so anyway,
so then,
but then I started dating a,
uh,
a girl from New York,
when I was in Chicago.
And,
um,
she,
that was more of where media happened and she knew people who are actually
getting jobs at magazines.
And I was like,
oh,
getting a job at a magazine is actual thing.
And then we dated for awhile.
We did it for like four or five years.
And then,
um,
she eventually broke up with me,
which was like one of the more profound experiences of my life.
And that was really what kicked me in the ass and sort of was like,
that happened.
Right.
You know,
in my late twenties.
And that was when I was like,
okay,
well if,
if you're going to like,
I don't know what you're,
you know,
I was telling myself like,
it was basically spite.
Like I was worried her plan was to go back to New York and go to film school and
I was just like,
terrified that she was going to become a famous director and I was going to be
sitting around supervising recess.
And so,
and so it was really that,
that was like,
okay,
you gotta,
you gotta try to,
you know,
this has been this dream that you haven't really admitted to yourself,
so you should just try to do it.
So,
um,
so I started trying to freelance and I had an internship at Harper's magazine
that I,
that I successfully applied to and got over the summer in between,
in between one of those years when I was teaching.
And,
uh,
and then eventually through Harper's I met,
I got to,
I got a job as the administrative assistant at this American life,
which was the public radio program and podcast.
It was just starting,
this is back in the,
like,
I guess back in [inaudible] 97,
uh,
October of [inaudible] 97 when I got that internship and when I got the,
administrative assistant assistant job,
um,
and it,
it had been the air on the air,
I think two years at that point and had become sort of,
you know,
had already made a name for itself but wasn't,
uh,
you know,
the,
beast that had that.
It is today,
uh,
the podcast king maker that it is today.
Um,
so,
uh,
so that's where,
that's,
that's that.
And that got me started,
you know,
I,
so I was an administrative assistant.
I sort of learned on the job.
It was like four of us back then.
It was IRA,
three producers and me.
Um,
and uh,
what a perfect,
perfect timing man.
What a great job.
Yeah,
just the four of you.
That's amazing.
And I learned a lot on the job,
but then I eventually,
but then,
you know,
so,
but I was the administrative assistant,
right?
I was like the one writing,
you know,
answering the mail and sort of like running to the post office and doing all
this stuff that needed to be done.
And because we were so short staffed back then and because like,
you know,
I really had no idea what he was getting himself into,
like a weekly hour of documentary radio where like the standards are higher than
anybody has ever had before.
Like he is a perfectionist,
you know,
and I learned a lot about the value of being a perfectionist from him.
Uh,
so,
but like,
you know,
the fact that he was trying to produce that with,
three producers who didn't really know what they were doing.
Cause then nobody knew what they were doing.
You know,
like he was,
he was trying to invent it.
So it was all hands on deck.
And so occasionally I would get to produce stuff or like help with the editorial
side of things.
And so I learned on the job,
but then there came a moment where I was like,
I produced this,
I'd actually produced semi,
like,
not what I would call producing now,
but I assisted in the creation of one of one of our big early shows,
which was a hour long documentary about Harold Washington and,
uh,
the first black mayor of Chicago.
And it was sort of a hit,
you know,
in the,
in the early days.
And,
and I came in after it had been,
you know,
just the bare to produce and I was working all kinds of crazy hours and I came
in after it aired the day,
the Monday after it aired.
And you fully expecting like,
okay,
now I've succeeded.
I passed this test and now I'm going to be made up producer.
And I said,
I wanted,
you know,
what would,
what did he think was he gonna make me produce it?
And he was like,
no,
I can't.
I don't,
I don't have money to make you a producer.
I don't have a position open and I need an administrative assistant.
And I was like,
oh,
well if you ever did have money and the position open,
would you hire me?
And he was like,
I don't know,
probably not because you don't have the experience still that I need.
You know,
there other people now who have that experience.
And it was like,
well,
what do I need to get that experience?
And he said,
well,
I don't know.
You probably should quit and start freelancing.
And I don't think he thought.
And now as a CEO of my own company,
I have this experience all the time where I'll sort of think out loud and I
don't realize that the people I'm talking to are like hanging on every word.
I'm sure that will happen with him.
But to me,
I was like,
okay,
well you've just given me the map of how I want to get my dream job,
so I'm going to quit.
So,
so I,
I put in my notice and I arranged like a loan from my parents to help me live
for the year,
uh,
like 10 grand.
I was like,
Oh,
if you give me 10 grand in lieu of graduate school,
I will get to make it as a freelance writer.
Uh,
and,
and we,
and I,
you know,
I,
I did,
I just tried to freelance and I've got stories in magazines and newspapers and
stuff like that,
and I continue to do radio.
And then a year and a half later,
I'd sort of built a little freelance career for myself,
which was going pretty well.
And then there was finally an opening at this American life and things hadn't
been going so well that I actually was like,
oh,
I'm not going to apply for that because now I'm doing this other thing.
And then finally somebody was like,
this was your dream job,
right?
And I was like,
yeah,
I guess it was.
And then I applied and then immediately I was like,
I really want this job.
So I that I got it.
So that was,
that was,
that was how that happened.
Wow.
So when you were freelancing,
the,
how did the,
let's see here,
the writing that you were doing,
did you find the writing took off more so than the radio where they taking off
in tandem?
Did the radio start to outpace the writing?
How did that,
how did that go on during your year of freelancing?
Well,
one of the things that I learned at that,
one of the biggest lessons I learned is never ever return your key card.
Uh,
so I still had my key card from Wbz,
uh,
the radio station where I was working,
coming up,
why good radio doesn't necessarily apply to television.
The value of perfectionism and the good end bad habits that Alex picked up from
this American life and Ira Glass.
But first a word from our sponsors,
the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling.
Kettlebells,
battle ropes,
maces steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for self improvement and you can see all of my favorite
gear at [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
that's o n n I t.com forward slash Tim and you can also get a discount on any
supplements,
food products.
I like hemp force,
I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on it.com forward slash Tim,
the Tim Ferriss show is also brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is your one stop shop for anything.
Graphic design related.
You need a logo,
you need a website,
you need a business card or anything else.
You get an original design from designers around the world who submit drafts for
you to review.
You are happy or you get your money back.
And I have used 99 designs for book cover ideas for the four hour body,
which went number one your times for banner ads.
And you can check out some of my actual competitions@ninetyninedesigns.com.
Forward Slash Tim,
you can also get a free $99 upgrade if you want to give it a shot.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim.
And now back to the show.
Did the
radio start to outpace the writing?
How did that,
how did that go on during your year of freelancing?
Well,
one of the things that I learned at that,
one of the biggest lessons I learned is never ever return your key card.
Uh,
so I still had my key card from Wbz,
uh,
the radio station where I had been working.
And so I would,
I could come in and I was,
I had some freelance projects that I was still working on at that,
at that station.
So they had hired me,
um,
to help produce this like poetry series that we're doing and,
and I,
and so I was picking up freelance work both in radio and on the writing side and
it was pretty equal.
Like I did a big radio documentary and I did something for a show called the
savvy traveler,
which was a travel show back then.
So within the public radio world there was like,
there was enough stuff that needed to be done and not that many people who were
like sort of free to do it,
that I can pick up,
you know,
sort of work at that point as well.
So it was about half and half.
Got It.
And,
uh,
how,
how did you come to then,
uh,
cofound planet money because,
I mean,
and,
and what was the timeline between getting landing that dream job as producer and
getting to planet money?
So that was,
I guess there was a year,
I mean,
there was a,
there was a decade in between,
uh,
getting the job.
I got the job in [inaudible] 99 and then a plan of money started in 2009 and one
of the nice things about working at this American life was that like the job was
constantly changing as I was there.
So I never had to,
like,
I never got bored like I started and I sort of took a long time.
That learning curve is pretty steep to get good at producing documentary radio.
So the first couple of years I was just trying to get my head above water and
figure out how this stuff worked and what people were talking about in these
edits and you know,
how to become better at recognizing good moments and all that stuff.
Um,
and then,
you know,
nine 11 was,
I mean it sounds cheesy and tried to say it,
but like not 11 sort of changed the focus of the show quite a bit.
We became,
you know,
we did a couple of shows on nine 11 and then we,
we,
we just got,
I think,
I think it made us a little bit more,
maybe we'd always been serious journalistically,
but I think it like felt like we were able to tell kinds of stories that were
both sort of journalistic and,
and human in a way that like,
felt like it filled a niche a little bit.
Um,
so,
so we did a lot of reporting on that and on the war and we went to an aircraft
carrier.
So that sort of changed.
Uh,
and then we did a TV show in there too.
So we did it,
this big TV show for showtime and I was an executive producer on the TV show.
So then I was like spending,
you know,
three or four years learning how to do TV,
which is a whole other huge learning curve.
And Man did,
we got our asses handed to us.
They're like,
oh,
we thought we were sort of storytelling experts.
Then we got into this new medium and we were like,
nothing we know works.
You know.
Can you give some examples because yeah,
I'd love some examples.
Yeah.
Well I mean it's like a y or an explanation of why it doesn't work.
Why,
why didn't it translate?
Well,
everything that I laid out to you about like what's good tape,
you know,
what you're going for in a radio interview.
Like that stuff doesn't apply to TV.
So like what I'm often,
you know,
you can make an amazing radio story out of one or two people telling a story
that happened to them in the past.
Like,
you know,
one of I first I won a big award called the third coast audio where at this
American life,
which was essentially two people at brother and a sister talking about a story
that happened to them,
you know,
60 years ago.
And it was just the two of them talking and we intercut them and we put in a
little bit of script and it was like one of the most moving stories that I've
ever produced.
And that's death on television.
You can't watch people telling a story about something that happened a long time
ago,
something about it just does not work.
Uh,
and we would try to produce these things and we'd be watching them and we'd be
like bored out of our skulls because there's just like you,
you just need so much more visual information than just watching people's,
you know,
watching people talk.
So that was one of the big lessons is sort of like,
it made me realize like,
oh TV.
That's why,
that's why reality television is so,
it's so big.
Like you can do it,
you can produce a story from the past,
but it's best to do it.
You have to just fill,
you have to give people something to watch.
And so you have to invent an entire visual story to go along with the story that
the person that's telling.
And that's just,
and that's really expensive.
So if you look at like an Errol Morris documentary or something like that,
where like there was that one where he will be an example of,
of one of those dongles war.
The fog of war was one that I saw.
So that's the one where he interviews,
um,
who's the interview,
uh,
are,
what am I,
what's his name?
The guy from Vietnam,
I haven't seen the movie.
Okay.
He interviews a famous general from Vietnam who is one of the ones that sort of
like was came under a lot of criticism.
He,
and it's a lot about like what went on back then,
you know,
in Vietnam.
And if you watch the movie now,
and I watched that movie around this time and I was like,
oh look at what he did.
Like he filled every second every frame with like invented imagery that he had
that he had to invent and come up with.
And it's so time consuming and so expensive versus sounds like sounds like man
on wire and man I'm why are exactly the same type of thing.
And if you watch that movie now,
so they have to do so much work to keep the screen covered with interesting
things to watch versus if you just take your average reality show where you've
got like two family members fighting with each other,
that's the,
that's the narrative crack in visual terms.
Like we are hardwired to watch that stuff.
It's so much cheaper.
You can turn the camera on and you watch two people fighting and you want to
watch it,
you know,
whether I mean,
and so and so it made me realize,
oh,
that's why TV is the way it is because that's what we want to watch.
You know,
we don't want to watch,
you know,
we want to watch things moving on screen.
Um,
so,
so it was really,
it was really hard.
And so we had to think,
think entirely differently.
We had to think entirely visually.
Like what's an interesting visual story versus an interesting audio story.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I,
I suggest anyone listening who enjoys reality television,
not learn too much about how it's produced because it will,
it will shatter the veneer.
Uh,
I remember I was,
I was talking to this guy who's worked on a bunch of reality shows you would
recognize and he said,
have you ever noticed how many of the arguments happen with people standing up
in the kitchen and someone's always mixing something psych.
Do you think that happens naturally?
I thought it was like,
that's a good point.
They are always arguing in the kitchen and someone's just absent mindedly
stirring something that we never really find out about it.
I wanted to come back to perfectionism because you mentioned you,
you learn the benefits of working with a perfectionist or maybe you said being a
perfectionist and you also mentioned the New Yorker.
So I had a chance,
very,
I was very fortunate to have the chance to study nonfiction writing for semester
with John McPhee,
who's a staff writer for the New Yorker and just a phenomenal,
phenomenal writer with a,
the the greatest attention to detail and structure of anyone I've ever met.
Uh,
but I'd be curious to hear sort of what,
what did you learn from working with,
with IRA?
What are the benefits of being a perfectionist or working for one?
MMM,
I think,
I think it basically,
it just,
what I learned is that,
um,
a lot of it is,
is just about the effort you put in.
And it's not about like,
you have to have,
you know,
you have to have a creative brain and like,
part of it is that,
you know,
you're just,
you're just sort of born with,
I guess partly you're,
you're,
you're sort of born with part of it at least.
But like watching IRA,
like sort of like work a lot of times he's just,
he just thinking about it longer than other people keep thinking about it and
then eventually he comes up with an idea.
That's good.
Uh,
and it just made me realize like that's how people get to good ideas as they go
through a lot of bad ideas first.
Um,
and that there's not really,
like,
occasionally a good idea comes to you first if you're lucky.
Uh,
but like usually it only comes after a lot of bad ideas.
And so what being a perfectionist is this sort of just like putting it a little
bit more time to think through the level one or the level two ideas and try to
get to something that's a little bit deeper.
Um,
and I think that's why we do as many edits as we do because often what happens
in an edit is you'll take a bad idea and you'll make it into a good idea over
the course of several edits.
Um,
and you'll have a,
an idea that's an,
a script that sort of like,
that's just getting you from one point to another point and then you'll be like,
you know what this is like,
it's like this.
And you'll come up with a good metaphor and then you'll be able to like,
oh,
that's a good metaphor to put in this part of the script.
It will really make it sing.
And then eventually you'll get to a part where you're like,
oh,
it feels like a revelation will now happen at this point in the piece.
Whereas before it was just moving from one,
you know,
from one thing that happened to the next.
Um,
so,
so I think that I learned that.
Um,
and then
are there any examples,
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
Ahead.
I'm going to come back and I was just going to ask you,
are there any examples of May perhaps from startup and reply all,
but it could be from previous shows of specific bad idea that was turned into a
good idea or that became a good idea?
Ah,
yeah.
I mean it happens every single time.
So,
um,
I'm trying to think of one that I could share that was like,
that's like,
it's easy enough to explain.
Um,
let me think for one more second.
I don't know.
This might be hard to do.
Uh,
sure.
We can,
we can,
we can come back to it.
I want to
pick up where you left off.
Let me,
yeah,
let me think about it.
It's like I couldn't come up with an example for you,
but,
okay.
Uh,
are there any habits that you picked up from IRA or the,
this American life team otherwise that you,
you still have a particular,
any particular working habits?
Either either or both.
So the good habit that I picked out is that I picked up is sort of like,
um,
like being committed to excellence.
Like that is something that I learned and I learned it from Iraq.
Like I think he really just hated to have something go out when it could have
been better.
And if he had an idea of how to make it better,
he would always almost always try to make it better.
Um,
and still does.
And that's like,
that was,
and I was not that way.
I was sort of like the kind of guy who was like,
yeah,
it's good enough,
you know?
And,
um,
and I,
what I realized is that,
but I,
I,
that was sort of a,
I think being way is a little bit of a,
of a dodge or a rationalization or an emotional sort of like thing you do to
sort of like,
not actually try to make things good.
Um,
you know,
cause trying to make things good as scary and you might fail and people might
say it sucks.
And we all know that.
And so we all like find our ways of rationalizing with it and a rationalizing
and that's,
and that's what I was doing.
I was like,
Hey,
it doesn't matter.
It's okay.
Uh,
and so working with IRA,
like I was like,
I know this is a guy who really cares about making it good and of all the things
to care about in the world,
that's one of the better ones,
you know,
just to try to make something excellent.
Like there's a lot of things that you can care about and that's a good thing to
care about.
So I learned that from him.
Uh,
and,
um,
there's a certain
comfort with crisis that he had that I'm afraid we're off on me also,
but I don't think it's a good thing.
I think that's a bad thing.
Um,
uh,
keep,
can you give any,
any,
any particular moment come to mind and we'll slip it in.
I mean,
I think,
I mean he just,
the show would,
was always like every,
for the entire time I worked at this American life,
it was always like up until the very last minute it was,
it was getting produced and edited and you know,
it was always like,
it was,
you know,
you'd be shocked the probably like 20 to 30% of the time you were like,
is it even going to go up?
And that's crazy.
You know,
over like 15 months old.
That's a lot to be like maybe 30% of the time we're really going to make it this
time.
I mean,
and,
and then at a certain point I was like,
Oh yeah,
we're always going to make it,
cause we always make it.
Uh,
but still,
it's like,
it's always right up into the right up until the last minute.
And um,
and it's better now.
It's way better now and a,
and like they've gotten like processes in place and stuff,
but uh,
and part of it is just audio is real time.
So even if you've been doing it for a long time,
you just can never quite get your head around how long it takes.
Um,
but part of it is a,
but part of it is just sort of like he's comfortable with that.
And I think in a certain way it focused his mind,
I think.
And I think it also focuses my mind.
I think like I've noticed myself doing like this,
this episode recently.
Like,
you know,
I'm the one who's writing it and I've got a whole bunch of other things that
have to do.
And on top of writing the script for this week's episode,
and it's like,
I sit down and I try to think,
but I'm like worried about this thing and I'm worried about that thing.
And I,
and in the back of my mind,
in this bad part that I learned,
I think is,
but it's gonna it'll,
I still have,
you know,
Monday morning at 5:00 AM I'll just get up early,
uh,
I still have that in,
in my,
in the back of my mind.
And then,
and at that point I'll have no choice and I will have to make it good.
And so I'll just leave it til that moment.
Um,
and I don't think that's not good.
And I like what it does is it drags everybody else into your crisis.
And so my,
you know,
Caitlin,
my producer is like dragged into my way of dealing my way of managing my time
and my way of sort of trying to make things good.
Um,
and that's,
I don't think,
I don't think she likes it and I didn't like it when I was a producer.
Like I felt like,
why is he saving everything until the last minute?
And I'm doing my exact same thing,
you know,
two minds.
Uh,
so that's,
uh,
that's because they learned all those,
you know,
I had 20 years of learning,
like,
yeah,
that was,
comes out.
It's fine.
It's so,
it's bad.
It's been bad,
you know?
So
yeah,
I've,
uh,
I've learned that that,
um,
have developed a similar level of comfort with crisis and last minute
turnarounds and,
uh,
I know from personal experience learn the hard way that that is a very fast way
to burn people out who haven't been conditioned and how you can lose really good
talent unfortunately.
Um,
the,
uh,
the commitment to excellence.
Are there any stories that come to mind of particular time?
For instance,
you handed,
you pass something on to Ira that you thought was good enough and he was like,
no,
not good enough and give it back to you.
Did that happen?
Oh,
I mean all the time,
like every single thing I ever read or did,
ah,
was it was never,
I never,
and this is not an exaggeration,
I don't think anybody ever in the history of this American life has ever had
this happen where though they'll read a draft,
even if it's the second or third draft and it'll be like,
and the,
and the answer is like,
all right,
it's all done.
There's always a new tweak and there's always something they can make it better.
Uh,
and um,
often there's like big thoughts and so,
and,
and again,
like,
and in the beginning it would sting a little bit.
It would be like,
God,
I just want to do one thing where it's like done and I'm,
I did it.
Right.
I took it really personally,
like I'm not doing it right.
And then it was only over time that I realized that like,
no,
you're not,
nobody does it.
Right?
Like the,
the first draft always sucks always for everybody.
And,
and,
and you just got to get over yourself a little bit.
Like,
it's not,
it's not about you and your ego is just about trying to make it better.
Um,
and then,
and then I realized that it was like that.
It was like,
that's really useful,
um,
to be able to have that muscle of like sort of like,
okay,
I trust myself enough that I'm not completed yet.
Uh,
but that it's always,
you know,
and I can be made better by other people's input and ideas.
That's essentially what an edit is.
And that's also a really good way of going through the world,
you know,
um,
is to,
is to try to be open to what people are telling you.
Um,
so that was a really,
I think that's,
you know,
the commitment to excellence means being comfortable,
hurting people's feelings and being comfortable,
having my feelings hurt.
Uh,
and to try to take the feelings out of it.
Um,
and,
and just talk about like what the thing you're trying to do is,
uh,
and that,
that's,
that was,
that was really useful to learn and would,
uh,
would I ever just say,
this isn't good enough?
Give it another shot or was it always a very specific feedback?
Always very specific feedback.
Always very specific.
Got It.
Not do it again.
Better like that.
That's sort of like,
um,
and that's also I think what being a good editor is because he's such a,
he was such a master of like the form that he,
he could tell you what was wrong and he could tell you like,
this isn't working for this reason.
And often it's like,
it's like really stupid little things.
Like,
so for example,
I can give you an example of this,
like from,
from this current episode of startup that we just did,
we,
it's all about burn out and basically we made the stupid decision to,
uh,
it's coming out today.
I think it will be up by the time this posts so you can,
people can listen to it.
Um,
but it's,
it was,
it basically we,
you know,
we,
we had this,
um,
we had the situation where like the hosts of reply all were working.
They ended up,
they were working late,
sort of like every day for like weeks.
And this was over the holidays.
When we made the stupid decision to try to put up a show on Christmas and on new
years eve.
Uh,
I don't know why we didn't take the week off,
but we didn't,
I think we felt like we were just knew we were just starting,
so it wasn't,
was too early to take time off or something.
Um,
so there were crashing trying to get these shows up on Christmas eve and on New
Year's eve and the shows weren't coming together very well and that we're just
working really,
really late.
And then,
uh,
one of our,
when Lisa started recording conversations with them about like how they were
feeling,
they were feeling super burned out and it was really good.
It's really good tape.
Um,
and so that's what the episode is about.
and we were scripting the episode and I started by,
this all happened,
it came to a head when I was out of town.
I was in San Francisco where my,
where my wife's family lives and we brought the kids out there over the
holidays.
But I was like,
it's supposed to be sort of a vacation,
but I was basically working the whole time,
but there was a day or two that I didn't work.
Uh,
and so I started the story by saying like,
all this happened while I was on vacation.
Uh,
it was just like one line.
Um,
but it,
it,
that one line put this whole like in the story was pretty good and we're just
telling the story and we,
like,
we were playing all this pretty entertaining tape of people talking about how
burned out they were and how their whole feelings about their jobs had changed.
And it's all very real,
very raw,
very entertaining.
Um,
but something about me saying that I was on vacation had this whole scoldy tone
all the way through it,
which is sort of,
I leave for one day and the whole place goes to hell.
Sorry,
which was not intended at all.
But that was,
it had that feeling,
it sort of cast the entire episode and this sort of like unpleasant light.
And so that's what I'm saying,
like it was,
and we were doing these edits and we were like,
this should be good.
Like the tape should be good.
But when we're listening,
we were like the s I have this,
I don't like it.
It's making me feel bad.
Not Good.
And,
uh,
and,
and it was,
and it wasn't until I was like one of our Starley put,
I think one of our other employees put,
uh,
put her finger on it.
She was like,
it's that,
that's the,
that's the thing that's making it feel bad.
Um,
is that,
is that just that line in the beginning where you just sort of give it colors
the whole way you're hearing this thing?
And so we just recrafted the beginning to be about like this transition in a
startup's life where you go from trying to raise the money to all of a sudden
you're running the running the organization.
Right.
And they're two totally different jobs.
And like this is an episode about how we were trying to manage the second phase
of actually running the company and dealing with our employees.
And so that gave it a much better context basically to listen to the story.
How far into the episode did you put your finger on that and,
and fix it.
So from the,
from the first kind of pitch meeting or decision to make the episode about
burnout,
what,
what amount of time elapsed before you're like,
oh,
okay,
that's the,
that's this issue we need to fix.
Uh,
it was probably like we did the first,
we did this edit and we actually put together a rough mix,
which we all listened to over the weekend and that was the one we were all like
freaking out because it wasn't working at all.
And we were like,
oh my God,
this is a stinker.
Uh,
and,
and the rough mix is like missing music.
It's just a bunch of tape strung together.
Yeah.
I mean there's a little bit more than that cause it was like we had a really
good guy doing it.
But yes,
it was like,
uh,
the levels went all mastered and everything like that and we knew that we were
going to come.
Do you do Skype?
Do you do like scratch audio for the script as well or,
no,
we,
we had recorded the script.
We had recorded the script,
so we'd done the whole thing like weed.
It was,
this was actually more work than we normally do.
Normally this would have been the second edit,
but we were like sort of behind the guns were like,
well maybe this will work.
So,
but it didn't.
Um,
so,
so it was essentially like a second edit and we did the second edit.
Um,
and we realized that it wasn't working and then it was over the weekend
basically that we were thinking about it.
And then this morning was when we sort of like,
I came in and rewrote,
rewrote the top based on sort of notes that certainly had given me last night,
a 10.
Um,
and there's a couple other things that were happening in the episode that we're
also sort of like robbing it of its,
of its power,
uh,
that we changed as well.
But,
uh,
but yeah,
it took,
it was probably like a couple days of sort of like sitting and thinking with it.
That's another thing that I learned from Iraj also about excellence.
Excellence is just tricks,
you know,
it's just managing your time and your expectations.
Um,
because there's this panic where you do,
like when I first heard the rough mix,
I was panicked because I was like,
this is bad,
this is a bad show.
Um,
but like,
but I have seen,
but then I had to remember like,
okay,
but you thought some part of it was good in the beginning and you have to go
back and remember what was the part that was good.
And there's some reason that something that was good has not become bad.
There's something that you're doing wrong,
you have to fix.
It's not a,
it's not a crisis.
You know what I mean?
It's just sort of like,
it's a problem to solve.
Uh,
and you know,
and that's,
it's just hard to remember that sometimes.
Like you just get.
And I think that's what,
you know,
with experience,
you start to realize like you've done it enough times,
like you've taken something that was bad and you've made a good that you realize
like it's,
it's,
uh,
it's not the end of the world or it's not even,
it's not like something that can't be fixed because that's the feeling you feel
like,
oh my God,
there's nothing to be done.
Like the thing that I thought was good is bad.
So I'd love to talk about,
um,
ask just a few more long form questions,
a couple of fast ones and then,
then we can wrap up.
But the,
I want to talk about turning a bad situation into a good one.
A very specifically,
I'd love to chat about startup episode number nine.
And we made a mistake.
So,
uh,
and,
about being attacked and villainized.
So maybe just for context,
if you could explain to people what that mistake was and then I'd love to dig
into that a little bit.
Yeah.
So we,
we,
we do these ads on the show there.
We have two ads in the middle of the show.
Uh,
and we,
we,
we produce our ads documentary style.
So what we tried to do is we just try to interview people,
either in the company or users of the company about their own real experiences.
And we,
and we turn those into little 45 minute long segments for,
for as our advertisements.
Um,
and one of our sponsors with Squarespace and the website company.
And what we were doing is we were talking to different Squarespace users about
their Squarespace sites.
Uh,
and we'd found this kid,
this lovely,
charming little boy who had a Squarespace site,
uh,
that he used for,
for Minecraft.
And we'd done this interview with them and it would have been lovely.
And,
um,
and then we put it up and we realized that we had never told him or his mother
that it was for an ad.
We had just,
and she had the impression that this kid was going to be on this American life,
like that her son was gonna be on this American life.
Um,
and then she got,
and then she heard from a friend that it was actually used in this ad.
And then she,
she got very upset and she went on Twitter and was talking about it on Twitter
and she had a lot large Twitter following.
And so a lot of her Twitter followers were,
were you know,
upset as well.
And then we started digging into the details and it was like a little bit even
worse because like it turned out that the email that we'd sent to her sort of,
you know,
given the impression that I did still work at this American life,
which was made it seem even sleazier.
I know it was just the,
it was less,
it was like really bad screw up on our part that that seemed to her quite
logically and rightfully that had been on purpose and an intentional deception.
And I enjoyed the episode for a host of reasons,
but I mean the first of,
first of which is we all make mistakes.
The second of which is how quickly things can spiral or seemingly spiral out of
control with the Internet and social media.
And how much of a crisis it can seem like.
And just like you working as a producer,
uh,
you know,
I've been sort of on the front lines online for a good period of time now.
So when when someone's like,
oh,
like this,
this like parody piece came out about your book in The New York Times and now
I'm just like,
Huh,
interesting.
I guess I should take a look at it later this afternoon.
I don't have the like,
oh my God,
the sky is falling.
Everything is over.
Uh,
response.
Not Always,
which we very much had.
I definitely realize that now.
Like it was like sort of like,
and there was a couple of people who are sort of visiting the office around that
time and they were like,
we think you're overreacting.
And it was like,
it just,
it,
which we definitely were,
I think.
Uh,
but it definitely,
it did feel like this,
like the company was so new and so young and we,
and you know,
we've managed to do this thing,
which,
which I wasn't sure I was going to be able to pull off,
which was sort of like to document making all these mistakes,
you know,
and still have people like along for the ride with you.
You know what I mean?
Right.
And like,
cause a lot of times when you,
a lot of times when you make mistakes,
you're not at your best or your worst,
you know,
you're sort of the,
your unpleasant side or the part of you that's sort of a dick or whatever is
sort of coming forward and uh,
to sort of air all that and still have people sort of on our side and supporting
the company and supporting the show.
We felt like we were already walking a tight rope and this felt like this was
going to be the thing that knocked us off.
Um,
and
no,
definitely.
And what I was curious to ask you is,
as someone who's been on the documenting side for so long,
uh,
looking at different situations,
documenting other people's lives,
perhaps painting them not in a negative light but in a,
in a,
in a neutral or a comprehensive light,
if you went back,
uh,
to say,
interviewing people in covering people for hard hitting news or something like
that.
Um,
like has your viewpoint changed or your,
your feelings about that?
Because a lot of journalists absolve themselves of the damage they might do to
someone if it gets a lot of clicks are a lot of views or a lot of listens.
And I'm just,
I know that this American life is,
is,
uh,
at least all of the episodes I've heard or are very constructive.
But I'm just wondering how,
how your feeling about how your feelings as a journalist or documentarian,
uh,
changed as a result of becoming a target yourself?
Well,
this is a bad cause.
I was like,
this is bad mix.
I was panicked,
recorded the script.
We had recorded it as well or no,
do like scratch audio for the screw going to come do you do Skype,
do you do it and everything like that.
And we knew that we were kind of,
the levels went all math,
the internet spiral out of control.
Things can spiral or seemingly the second of which is how quickly,
first of which is,
we all make mistake of reasons,
but I mean the first [inaudible] for a host,
I enjoyed the episodes
and then an intentional disassembly that had been on purpose logically and
rightful to her quite seemed part that that really bad screw up on are there was
this,
it was like a year.
I know.
It was just the made it seem even sleazy to work at this American life,
which was not always,
which we've uh,
response.
Everything is over.
Oh my God.
The size.
Yeah.
Balling afternoon.
I don't have the like home,
I guess I should take a look at it later.
The sentence leg.
Huh?
Interesting book in The New York Times and now I'm parody piece came out about
your this like when when someone's like,
oh,
like the good period of time now.
So online for,
I've been sort of on the front lines,
uh,
you know,
I've think you working as a producer it seemed like and just allow much of a
crisis.
It can cedia and,
yeah,
and social media given the impression that I did,
you know,
her sort of email that we'd sent to us because like it turned out that the
wasn't,
it was like a little bit even where all these mistakes,
you know,
making like to document or I was going to be able to pull off which was,
which I wasn't sure which you this thing,
you know,
we've managed to and we knew new and so young,
it's like the company was solely,
it did feel like a,
but it definitely,
definitely where I think
and it was like it just,
we think you're overreacting visiting the office around that time.
And they were like,
and there was a couple of people who are sort of dies that now like it was like
sort of like already much had.
I would definitely
different situations documenting uh,
looking at it for so long.
The documenting side as someone who's been on you is from Elaine.
What I was curious to ask him.
No.
Um,
it's going to be the thing that knocked us off a rope and this felt like this
was like we were already walking,
attempting,
supporting the show.
We felt on our side and supporting the kind of still have people.
So not to sort of air all that coming forward and Dick or whatever.
It's sort of tied or the part of you that's sort of,
you're sort of the,
your unpleasant see your best or your worst,
you know,
it's just,
I know a lot of listens and if it gets a lot of clicks are a lot of the damage
that they might do to someone that's absolve themselves.
A lot of journal about that because I'll be judged or you or your feelings.
Like has your viewpoint changed that were hard hitting news or something like
people in covering people for interviewing,
uh,
to say you went back
if neutral or comprehensive light light but in a,
in,
in an APP's painting,
them not in a negative leather people's lives
when you make mistakes,
you're not injured and everything like that.
We knew that we were going to come.
Do you do Skype?
Do you do like scratch audio for the script as well or no,
we,
we had recorded the script.
We had recorded Amex.
I was panicked because I was like,
this is bad.
This is a bad show self.
Hmm.
Well,
salt of becoming a target.
You're a changed as a journalist or documentarian.
How your feelings as a Ji Ling about how,
how your feet,
but I'm just wondering,
a constructive,
I've heard or are very sa at least all of the episodes of the,
this American life is,
is my God.
The Sky is falling.
Everything is over.
Uh,
response.
Not Always,
which we will work at this American life,
which was made it seem even sleazier.
I know it's just the,
there was this,
it was like a really bad screw up on our part that that seemed to her quite
logically and rightfully that had been on purpose because like it turned out
that the email that we'd sent to her sort of,
you know,
given the impression that I did still yes,
social media and how much of a crisis it can seem like and just like you working
as a producer,
uh,
you know,
I've been sort of on the front lines online for a good period of time now.
So when when someone's like,
oh,
I like this,
this like parody piece came out about your book in The New York Times and now
I'm just like,
Huh,
interesting.
I guess I should take a look at it later.
The side
is that now,
like it was like sort of like,
and there was a couple of people who are sort of visiting the office around that
time and they were like,
we think you're overreacting.
And it was like,
it just,
which we definitely were,
I think.
Uh,
but it definitely,
it did feel like this,
like the company was so new and so young and we,
and you know,
we've managed to do this thing,
which,
which I wasn't sure I was going to be able to pull off,
which was sort of like to document making all these mistakes and it was like a
little bit even were sort of the your unpleasant side or the part of you that's
sort of a dick or whatever is sort of
people's lives perhaps painting them not in a negative light but in a,
in a,
in a neutral or a comprehensive light.
If you went back,
uh,
to say,
interviewing people and covering people for hard hitting news or something like
that.
Um,
like has your viewpoint changed or your,
your feelings about that?
Because I'll,
a lot of journalists absolve themselves of the damage they might do to someone
if it gets a lot of clicks are a lot of views or a lot of listens.
And I'm just,
I know sa,
at least all of the episodes I've heard or are very constructive.
But I'm just wondering how,
how your feeling about how your feelings as a journalist or documentarian
changed as a result of becoming a target yourself?
Well show this is a bad cause.
I was like,
this is bad mix.
I was panicked,
recorded the script
ripped as well or no,
we do like scratch audio for the screw going
to come.
Do you do Skype,
do you do it and everything like that.
We knew that we were at times when you make mistakes,
you're nodding logically and rightful to her.
Quite seemed part that that really bad screw up on are there was this,
it was like a year,
I don't know,
it's just made it seem even sleazy and work at this American life,
which was not always,
which we've uh,
response.
Everything is over.
Oh my God,
the sky is falling.
This American life is,
is your best or your worst,
you know,
it's you coming forward and uh,
to sort of air all that and still have people sort of on our side and supporting
the company and supporting the show.
We felt like we were already walking a tight rope and this felt like this was
going to be the thing that knocked us off.
Um,
no,
definitely.
And what I was curious to ask you is just like,
Huh,
interesting and look in the New York Times and now I'm parody piece came out
about your this like when when someone's like,
oh,
like the good period of time now.
So online for,
I've been sort of on the front lines.
Uh,
you know,
I think you working as a producer it seemed like and just low,
much of a crisis.
It can cedia and how social media given the impression that I did,
you know,
her sort of email that we'd sent to us because like it turned out that the blade
that had been on purpose as someone who's been on these mistakes,
you know,
making like to document where I was going to be able to pull off,
which was,
which I wasn't sure do this thing,
you know,
we've managed and we ate and new and so young.
It's like the company was solely,
it did feel like a,
but it definitely,
definitely where I think it and it was like it just,
we think you're overreacting visiting the office around that time.
And they were like,
and there was a couple of people who are sort of has that now.
Like it was like sort of like,
I guess I should take a look at it later.
The side or the part of you that's sort of,
you're sort of the,
your unpleasant southern.
It was like a little bit even where I'm the documenting side user,
a lot of listens and I'm just,
if it gets a lot of clicks are a lot of the damage they might do to someone
that's absolve themselves.
A lot of journal about that because I'll be finished.
Are you or your feelings like has your viewpoint changed that were hard hitting
news or something like people in covering people for interviewing,
uh,
to say you went back if neutral or comprehensive light,
but in a,
in a,
an APP's painting them not in a negative leather people's lives.
Pred Dick or whatever.
It's sort of for so long it was less,
it was like really bad screw up on our part that that seemed to her quite
logically and rightful items when you make mistakes you're not used it and
everything like that.
And we knew that we were going to come.
Do you do Skype?
Do you do like scratch audio for the script as well or no,
we,
we had recorded the script.
We had recorded Amex.
I was panicked for lane.
What?
I was curious to ask.
No.
Um,
it's going to be the thing that knocked us off.
Hey Rope.
And this felt like this was like,
we were already walking a,
in supporting the show we thought of on our side and supporting the kids still
have people.
So now to sort of air all that coming forward and your best or your worst,
you know,
you see this American life is God,
the sky is falling,
everything is over.
A response,
not always,
which we will work at this American life,
which was made it seem even sleazier.
I know it,
it's just the cause.
I was like,
this is bad.
I wasn't,
it was like a little bit even where you're sort of the your unpleasant side or
the part of you that's sort of,
I guess I should take a look at it later.
The size that now,
like it was like sort of like,
and there was a couple of people who are sort of visiting the office around that
time and they were like,
we think you're overreacting.
And it was like,
it just,
which we definitely were,
I think.
Uh,
but it definitely,
it did feel like this,
like the company was so new and so young and we,
and you know,
we've managed to do this thing,
which,
which I wasn't sure I was going to be able to pull off,
which was sort of like to document making all these mistakes,
you know,
as someone who's been on laid that had been on purpose because like it turned
out that the email that we'd sent to her sort of,
you know,
given the impression that I did still yes.
And social media and how much of a crisis it can seem like and just like you
working as a producer,
a dick or whatever,
it's sort of other people's lives.
Perhaps painting them not in a negative light but in a,
in a,
in a neutral or comprehensive light.
If you went back,
uh,
to say,
interviewing people in covering people for hard hitting news or something like
that.
Like has your viewpoint changed or your,
your feelings about that?
Because a lot of journalists absolve themselves of the damage that they might do
to someone if it gets a lot of clicks are a lot of use are a lot of listens and
I'm done.
The documenting side recorded the script.
We had recorded it as well or no,
we do like scratch audio for the screw.
Gonna come do you do Skype,
do you do
and everything like that.
We knew that we were,
a lot of times when you make mistakes you're not logically and rifle to her
quite seemed part that,
that really bad screw up.
It was this,
it was like
for so long.
Uh,
you know,
I've been sort of on the front lines online for a good period of time now.
So when when someone's like,
oh,
like this,
this like parody piece came out about your book in The New York Times and now
I'm just like,
Huh,
interesting you is,
this is a bad show self.
Hmm.
Well,
salt of becoming a target,
you're a changed as a journalist or documentarian.
How your feelings as a year.
I know it's just the made it seem even sleazy or work at this American life,
which was not always,
which we've uh,
response everything is over.
Oh my God,
the sky's falling ever.
That this American life is,
is your best or your worst,
you know,
it's you coming forward and uh,
to sort of air all that and still have people sort of on our side and supporting
the company and supporting the show.
We felt like we were already walking a tight rope and this felt like this was
going to be the thing that knocked us off.
Um,
and no,
definitely.
And what I was curious to ask next.
I was panicked like this,
like the company was solely,
it did feel like a,
but it definitely,
definitely where I think it and it was like,
it just,
we think you're overreacting visiting the office around that time.
And they were like,
and there was a couple of people who are sort of eyes that now like it was like
sort of like,
I guess I should take a look at it later.
The side or the part of you that's sort of,
you're sort of the,
your unpleasant southern.
It was like a little bit even worse cause I was like,
this is bad.
Did you lean about how,
how your feet,
but I'm just wondering a constructive I purred or are very,
at least all of the episodes just I,
I know,
uh,
looking at different situations,
documenting
very much had I definitely real afternoon,
I don't have the like homeless and an intentional deception
and I enjoyed the episode like,
and just low,
much of a crisis.
It can cedia and how social media,
given the impression that I did stuff,
you know,
her sort of email that we'd sent to us because like it turned out that the blade
that had been on purpose as someone who's been on all these mistakes,
you know,
making like to document or I was going to be able to pull off,
which was,
which I wasn't sure which do this thing,
you know,
we've managed to do and we ate and new and so young seemed to her quite
logically and rightful items.
When you make mistakes,
you're not here.
Next,
next time you're in San Francisco to visit the,
uh,
the inlaws are the wife's family.
Should we should put together a dinner of some time just for,
just for the hell of it.
I got that done.
That,
that'd be a good time.
I mean,
who do you,
do you have people like that that you're like,
oh,
that's,
that guy is doing her.
Well,
she's,
she's really got to go on like
I do.
Uh,
and you know,
one of them is a friend,
a close friend of mine who was in your first episode.
Uh,
that's Chris Saka.
So as,
as,
as an as an investor of Eight,
I've been a early stage investor and a lot of companies like whether it be
Twitter or advisor to Uber,
et Cetera,
Evernote.
And,
uh,
Chris was one of the,
the very early mentors I had and he's a close friend,
but he also is very,
very good,
obviously at the early stage startup game.
So it was really Mike maples junior initially.
Uh,
and then Chris Saka and also a guy named naval Ravikant who,
uh,
are spectacularly good at what they do.
And they have a mythos,
a methodical way of dissecting certain types of problems.
And so I tried to,
I enjoy learning their respective recipes.
You know,
they're kind of algorithms that they use for evaluating things because,
uh,
they're all clearly effective,
but they're also sometimes very different,
which I find fascinating.
Um,
so in the,
in the startup world,
since I'm not,
there are people just because I'm running,
you know,
I,
I've,
I'm,
I have my,
my own fledgling podcast,
uh,
and then the,
the blog,
which is much more established and so on.
There are people in the,
uh,
and I don't really love the content creation label,
but people in the,
the content sphere,
whether it be audio or spoke or a written word or even video and television
that,
that I really respect a lot.
Um,
you know,
I find what Morgan Sperlock does very fascinating,
for instance,
who was kind of in front of the camera and behind the camera,
but now it does both,
uh,
including things that make him very much behind the scenes.
Um,
so yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I guess I've been on my own.
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
No,
I know a couple people who are,
who are working with his company and he seems to,
yeah,
it seems like a great,
you know,
he seems like he's doing a really good job running.
Yeah.
He's a,
he had a nice hub for,
for where,
you know,
where cool things can happen.
Yeah.
He's very good at the establishing rapport with just any,
any group you can imagine.
Uh,
so with,
you know,
inside,
inside man I think it is.
I don't think it's inside job inside man.
It's a,
it's really split.
Yeah.
Just incredible to see how quickly he can establish rapport with,
with people.
Um,
so I'm going to ask you the UPPP reps,
the,
the opposite of the word successful,
not failure,
but what's the first face that comes to mind when you think of the,
and you're a very nice guy,
so this might be hard to,
hard to answer,
but what's,
what's the first face that comes to mind when you think of the word?
Punchable
punchable
Oh,
Tim,
that could be your answer too.
Yeah,
no,
I uh,
I'm just trying to decide.
I will tell you this,
like,
I feel like coming from,
um,
I guess coming from the not like the nonprofit world,
like where I,
I never had,
um,
this is the first,
this is my first fulltime job in the for profit sector.
Being the CEO of my own company,
uh,
since I was a hell of a way to a hell of a way to start.
And I think,
and coming from the public radio world and the,
and the not nonprofit world at large,
like I do think there is a,
um,
a way that we conceive of,
we conceive of ourselves as punchable in that world.
Like that we're like,
not that we need,
um,
that like we need to be shielded from this,
this world of profit.
And like somehow that there's like a,
that it's,
that it's dangerous and it's filled with people who will sort of eat you for
breakfast.
And,
and I think,
you know,
I mean,
that's like a gross exaggeration and lots and lots of people in the nonprofit
world or like,
you know,
like this is like buy,
this is a gigantic,
gigantic overgeneralization just so you know.
But like,
but I do think there's like a slight attitude that I ran into at a public radio
and other places that like the,
the,
that we're shielded in this world from having to do,
uh,
you know,
from like some sort of like,
angry or,
or sort of like,
you know,
macho or malevolent forces in the for profit world.
And,
uh,
and that's like,
you know,
and that,
that's been one of the nice things.
And maybe,
you know,
who knows,
maybe I'm going to like,
get like my ass kicked so soon.
I probably will.
And like,
I'll be like,
you know,
God,
I wish I was still in the nonprofit sector or whatever,
but,
but there was like,
there's something about like,
just sort of going out and being part of this sort of,
you know,
market economy in a really,
really straight forward way.
Uh,
that's freeing.
And it doesn't feel like it doesn't,
you know,
doesn't it feels like the way it should be and not scary.
You know,
it's like,
Yep.
That's it.
Yeah.
No,
it makes it makes perfect sense.
I mean,
I think that it gives you,
I,
I've,
uh,
I work with a number of,
of nonprofits like donors choose in New York,
which is run really leanly actually very much like a for profit in that way.
But yeah,
the for profit world gives you some metrics that are very clear to play with.
Uh,
that,
that I think can be freeing in a way.
Um,
because there's,
there's very little ambiguity about it.
Yeah,
no,
that metric thing was huge for me.
Yeah.
That we didn't have,
like it was like sort of decisions you didn't,
it's a very,
you make decisions for,
then you end up making decisions for all sorts of other weird sort of arbitrary
reasons which like what does the director like it or do our donors like it or
not?
Like,
do people like it?
It doesn't,
this is something that should exist in the world,
you know,
that people value enough to pay for.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
Uh,
if now on that point,
you've,
uh,
you've kind of,
not switched teams.
It's not like they're opposing teams,
but you've,
you've done a lot since you,
you were,
you were first teaching eighth grade science obviously.
Uh,
what would the old,
what would the old you say to the new you or what would the old you think of the
new you?
Uh,
owns me with,
think of the new me.
I think it depends on which,
which stage you go to,
but like,
um,
you know,
going back to like,
sort of the college and post college like the old me would think would probably
think the new me with some kind of sellout maybe.
Um,
I was never that,
like,
sort of like that strident ever.
Uh,
but I was definitely more strident that I am now.
and I definitely would have,
you know,
and I was definitely a sort of a little bit more suspicious of
the profit motive when I was younger.
Uh,
so I would probably be like,
what,
you know,
like what have you done with your life?
I mean,
the old me would also be like,
you're an old man and all you do is like go and you have like these two kids
that are just,
you know,
I would've looked at myself with horror,
I'm sure like my life.
I never,
I haven't seen a movie and God knows out along.
I don't travel anymore.
Uh,
you know,
so.
All right,
one more question for you.
So if,
if you could give your 20 year old self one piece of advice,
what would it be?
Um,
this is gonna Sound Corny,
but,
uh,
don't be,
don't be so afraid.
You know,
I think,
I think I organized a lot of my choices based on sort of what I thought I could
do rather than what I wanted to do.
And I did that because I didn't want to try to do the things that I wanted to
do.
Um,
because I was afraid I would fail at them.
So I think I organized a lot of my life around fear for this first,
you know,
that first decade after college.
Uh,
and I'd tell my Scott,
don't be afraid to,
you know,
go out and just like fall on your face a little bit more.
Sorry.
Okay.
Oh,
that's good advice.
Alex,
just in closing,
I know you have to run a where can people find more about you?
About what you're up to?
Yeah.
Uh,
well you can listen to the startup podcast.
It's all right there.
Uh,
and that,
and that's at our website,
gimlet media.com.
Both our shows are their startup and reply all,
uh,
and you know,
all sorts of stuff about our company and about me.
Wonderful.
All right Alex,
I will let you get going.
I really enjoyed the,
the masterclass.
I will put tons of links in the show notes for everybody,
including links to the show is to get the media to the gear that you use in the
field to creative live class and uh,
and much more.
[inaudible] thanks so much for the time.
And don't forget.
This is a two part episode with Alex and we're going to give you a sample of
that next part,
the art of the interview,
which is a class of his.
It is fantastic so we'll give you a few minutes of that and please continue
listening.
But first just a short word from our sponsors.
The Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling.
Kettle bells,
battle ropes,
maces steel clubs.
Sounds like a torture chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for self improvement and you can see all of my favorite
gear at [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
that's o n n I t.com forward slash Tim and you can also get a discount on any
supplements,
food products.
I like hemp force,
I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on it.com forward slash Tim,
the Tim Ferriss show is also brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is your one stop shop for anything.
Graphic design related.
You need a logo,
you need a website,
you need a business card or anything else.
You get an original design from designers around the world who submit drafts for
you to review.
You are happy or you get your money back.
And I have used 99 designs for book cover ideas for the four hour body,
which went to Number One New York Times for banner ads.
And you can check out some of my actual competitions@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim,
you can also get a free $99 upgrade if you want to give it a shot.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim and now back to the show.
So this is starting with on this American life a while ago.
And um,
the setup is that if this actor Tate Donovan Donovan is,
it was a sort of a character actor.
He'd been,
you know,
sort of on a couple of different shows,
but he didn't get recognized very much.
And then he had a like a stint on friends and all of a sudden he was trying to
get recognized and it was really exciting for him to be recognized because he
finally got to be the celebrity that he always wished that he could be the
celebrity that he would have wanted to meet before he was famous.
Uh,
so when he got recognized and so one and this story happens when one night he
was out at this Broadway show and a lot of people were coming up to him and be
like,
Hey,
I saw you.
And he was able to like talk to people and be very magnanimous and say thank you
so much.
It really means a lot.
And he was like posing for pictures for people and it was at the show.
It was happening over and over and over again.
I was,
I was exactly how I wanted to be.
I was doing it,
I was doing great.
And then
the kid with the camera came along,
this nervous kid,
I know he must have been 16 years old.
He's in a rented Tuxedo,
unbelievably like shy and awkward.
And he's got acne and he's got a camera in his hand and underneath the marquee
is his date.
Who is it?
Literally like a Po,
a prom dress,
and she's got a corsage and she's really,
you know,
nervous and sort of clutching your hands.
And he sort of comes up to me and he sorta mumbles something like,
you know something about a picture.
And I'm like,
I just feel for him.
So I'm like,
oh,
absolutely my gosh.
Or I have no problem,
my God,
you poor thing.
And,
and I go up to his,
his girlfriend,
I wrapped my arms around her and I'm like,
Hey,
where are you from?
Fantastic.
Going to see the play.
It's great.
And the guys sort of not taking the photograph very quickly.
He's just sort of staring at me and he's got his camera's hands and it's done by
is like chin,
you know,
and,
and uh,
she's very stiff and awkward and I don't know what to do.
So I just leaned across and I kiss her on the cheek and I'm like,
all right,
God,
take the picture,
hurry up.
Do you guys want to find out what happens next?
That's a story.
Uh,
when you want to wait.
So what,
that is the power of a good narrative.
So when I talk about,
I'm talking about like those two basic things,
you're going for emotion and narrative.
We as humans are hardwired,
I believe,
to listen to narrative and,
and it's a very simple sort of the mechanics of narrative or very simple.
There's like a sequence of actions and those sort of rising action and it's
culminating in something.
Um,
and you were in the middle of that sequence of actions and you were about to get
to the culmination and I stopped it and it's frustrating and you really want to
know what happens next and you would never,
if you are listening to this,
have turned off that podcast or that radio story at that moment.
And that is a good story.
And that's why you want to operate in stories.
That's why you,
when you're interviewing people,
you want to get their stories out of them.
Um,
and you want to get them talking in stories because stories are what
we want to hear.
Yeah,
you enjoyed this episode.
You're going to love what I have coming,
all sorts of crazy experiments,
incredible guests,
and you can very easily not miss any of it.
Just subscribe on iTunes or you can check out all of my guests as well as my
blog that has one to 2 million readers per month@fourhourworkweek.com all
spelled out,
four hour work week.com.
That's where I chronicle all of my insane self experimentation and I would love
to hear from you.
So please reach out to me on Twitter,
twitter.com forward slash t Ferris,
t,
F,
e R,
r,
I s,
s or on facebook@facebook.com forward slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two
s's,
of course.
And until next time,
thank you so much for listening.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.